GUEST SPEAKER: Dear
secretary of the interior,
thank you for inviting
me to weigh in
on this very important
counter study
to and indefensible claim
by the heritage society.
As you know, this
conservative organization
is pushing for free enterprise
in limited government.
So they're merely
trying to deregulate
to support free enterprise
and to help their allies,
including industry
to save some money.
As you know, in 1970
the EPA was formed
to control the extreme
pollution of water and air
in this country.
These conditions were causing
fish kills, bird [INAUDIBLE],,
and having negative
effects on human health.
[INAUDIBLE] control policy
suggests that clean [INAUDIBLE]
were established, also
in 1970, to regulate
the use of these pollutants.
The goal was to protect the
ecosystem and human health
for future generations.
And so far, it's been
effective from the point
of view of scientists and
environmental advocates.
It's a success.
Pollution has been
vastly reduced
to [INAUDIBLE]
[? implementation ?]
these policies and this is
a tremendous achievement,
so why stop now is our argument.
There are still extremely
endangered ecosystems
in the country and
industries are constantly
inventing new products that
have new negative effects
on the environment that
we're not yet aware of.
So the study we conduct
to challenge the heritage
societies claims
will have four parts.
First, we'll focus on
science benchmarks.
We'll also focus
on topic opinion,
propose an administrative
review of the EPA,
and a review by the
Justice Department.
So for our first pillar,
the scientific measurements
will hire an outside team
of environmental scientists
to evaluate air
and water quality
and how it has
improved since 1970.
Scientists must also
prove that threats
to the health of
our environment,
to our clean air and
water, still exists
and that regulation of anything
should be expanded and improved
and not reduced or terminated.
We need to frame our study and
focus on scientific results
to counter the
heritage societies
focus on economic results.
We will design a study based
on science and numbers,
because that is how
you will measure
the efficacy of a program
like the clean air act.
So focus on how you
improve vehicle emissions,
how efficient bird
have bounced back.
And this will help
legitimate our study
in the eyes of the
scientific community
and we'll also involve
the scientific community.
We can also come at
this from an angle that
will satisfy the business
community and congress.
We can require companies to
maintain certain air quality
standards as a means
to spur innovation.
We've been innovative
in this regard so far.
We've invented cleaner
fuels, renewable energy
and we believe that the American
people can invent even better,
cleaner technologies
and the regulation
will help inspire that.
Our second component will
focus on the public stance
on the issue of
environmental protection.
We're in an unprecedented era
in environmental awareness
and the public is
completely behind it.
I'd like to bring your attention
to a very revealing ruling that
just came out in the last
few weeks in Massachusetts.
Two men used their lobster
boat to block a coal shipment
from passing through
the channel on its way
to Brayton Point Power Plant.
The men were on trial
for several counts
and faced several years
in jail and the judge
ruled that he approved
the use of necessity
as a defense for their actions.
In order to use the
necessity defense,
you have to prove that you were
in clear and imminent danger.
And in this
instance, the defense
argues the men in
their communities
were in clear and imminent
danger of climate change.
So the judge decreed they
had no legal alternative
to protect themselves
and their communities
other than to try to
block the coal shipment.
So the prosecutors subsequently
dropped the charges.
So obviously this is a
totally unprecedented case.
This is an exciting time for
environmental progressives.
Judges are going
rouge on this issue
and they're allowing
people a lot of room
to maneuver, to fight
environmental problems,
so we want to design a
policy [INAUDIBLE] that
involves the public energy
as much as possible.
So we're going to
educate the public,
we're going to use
some of our funding
to organize conferences and
small community advisory
committees.
These committees will call small
meetings in their communities
and discuss the EPA's
[INAUDIBLE] control policies
and they can weigh
in on whether or not
they think those policies
should continue at this time.
This method will give
our study legitimacy
in the eyes of the
public and in the eyes
of congress, who depend
on the public for voting.
I highly doubt a heritage
society did a public assessment
or reached out to the
public in their review,
so basically, we'll
get our study,
that added legitimacy that we
involved the public opinion.
And then, come election
time, the public
will play a role in the
political evaluation
of the heritage societies
policy suggestions.
And we'll also ask the public
to consider who the heritage
society is serving
in trying to overturn
these important policies.
The courts finally
ruled that the BP oil
spill was the result of gross
negligence and so we can ask,
are these the types of behaviors
the heritage society thinks
we no longer need
to regulate against.
OK.
Third component, we're going
to play the business community
into the heritage
society by holding
an administrative
review of the EPA.
They are arguing against the
efficiency of the program.
The EPA has had some
organizational problems in
the last few decades, so we're
going to go ahead and help them
out with that and also better--
organize better [? about ?]
EPA is good for everybody.
And that will satisfy the
business community, also,
to have some of
that what they see
as wasteful practices reduced.
Our fourth review
method, like I said,
is to involve the
Justice Department
and I'll remind you again of the
instance of the judge releasing
the environmental activists
who blocked the coal barge.
So the Justice
Department, as a whole,
we think should take a stand
on this issue of the right
to clean air and water,
so we're requesting
a judicial review of the
constitutionality of removing
[INAUDIBLE] policies
designed to protect
the people and the environment.
So in conclusion, I agree
with you, secretary,
that the study by the
heritage society is bogus
and we need to organize our
own review of command control
policies that
highlight their value.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.